yo bulacan podcast
special guest my brother doobie is here
yes sir
he brought a white claw he brought some
expensive tequila you
wanted the white claw that was for you i
would have never brought that did you
call it
you called me a teenage girl or
something yes man he's acting like a
college doctor he said what are you bro
what's going on here like [ __ ]
we brought the class a he wants a white
claw yo
i gotta see look look at him
look
[Laughter]
temporary producer can we get a [ __ ]
this is a good way to start it off right
here
i just spilled the claw yeah let me get
those paper towels
that that calls for another shot for
real all right let's take another shot
[ __ ] it the podcast has started i
spilled my white claw i still think i
might be
tripping off shrooms from austin texas
oh man that sounds like
we need i need to interview you about
that
cheers well now your table smells like
black cherry claw
black cherry calls the best clown
so good well [ __ ]
anyway doobie um
it's good to finally have you on the
show i know we had a couple of
pump fakes yeah i'm sorry man i'm sorry
all right you're busy you come to la now
you get [ __ ] done then you go
yeah it's that farther life yeah so uh
for people who don't know who the [ __ ]
you are who are checking this out
there's gonna be a lot of people
checking us out don't know you are kind
of give everybody a rundown
uh where you're from you know who is
doobie
um so my name doobie and make sure you
spell it right d-o-o-b-i-e
i hate what [ __ ] misspelled my
name it's irritating
they hit they hit you with the d-o-o-b
why people are [ __ ] those people
those people are [ __ ] slow
no man not at all yeah i'm from columbus
ohio
man um as you know i mean we have a lot
of talent now but when i was coming up
and i kind of popped three years ago on
youtube
a song called when the drugs don't work
it kind of went viral sparked my career
and
you know back then we didn't really have
nobody um
not from columbus anyway um there's a
lot of great ohio artists like shout out
trippy shout out
mgk you know is bowel from columbus
nah okay i didn't know yeah he's not
from columbus that i know of
i don't know he's from somewhere in ohio
right no he says he's from columbus but
i don't know
oh he says that oh you just never seen
him now i don't know nobody
i don't know nobody that knows that man
from glen
he was probably like eight years old
when he moved to be fair
so was he from there he was born there
but he's from there that's fair a lot of
people be born
places corrupt was born in philly but he
everyone think he's from l.a
exhibit exhibit was born in new mexico
see now that's crazy see that's
yeah so columbus ohio
yes sir big college town right yep ohio
state buckaroos
buckeyes that's like b college that's
yeah
i used to yo anytime i would like see a
[ __ ] at the club before i was married
of course i used to always say man that
[ __ ] is giving me the ohio state [ __ ]
eyes
[Laughter]
you ever have a [ __ ] give you the ohio
state [ __ ] eyes yeah
yeah time or two yeah a time or two
right it might have led to something
you might have ain't got nothing to do
with me fair enough
um yeah so you when the drugs don't work
is a record that
kind of puts you on but prior to that
you were uh
grinding like because i met you what
year did i meet
doobie was it like 2014 14. well now we
met
was that was it that does yesterday you
guys had a show in st pete with
with jelly yeah it was right after me
and you met type [ __ ]
yeah so um you you were kind of on the
road like
kind of soaking up game dj highlight
who's a maniac himself
um yeah columbus legend
you know you know what i couldn't stand
about highlight what the era when he
would be on
instagram covering his face and every
[ __ ] photo that was dude who is dj
highlighting
so [ __ ] cool let me cover my face i
do
i was like yo why does this guy cover
his [ __ ] face in every photo who the
[ __ ] does he think he is
some [ __ ] emo [ __ ] going on over in
columbus
nah but uh so so you ended up linking
with highlight
what year was that like 20 it's into
2013.
eight years and uh you know
a lot of people might think that like
[ __ ] happened overnight for you
there was a lot of a lot of uh a lot of
hard work what
what what what what do you think like
you know your journey
from from when you started to now like
the perseverance like was there ever a
point in time where you were like you
were questioning like this music [ __ ]
like whether or not you could actually
do it like and make a living off of it
like were you wasting your time
you know it was crazy when i was younger
and when i first met light and [ __ ] when
we first started doing it
we went through the artist development
stage and at that stage i
believed in myself so much i had so much
confidence like
it's going to happen regardless
regardless but then
you know it started becoming work you
know
it was like dude you have to do this
it's it's promoting yourself as get and
back then we were still going
door-to-door selling tickets
and cds out the trunk type [ __ ] like we
were still doing that we got the end of
that
you know what i'm saying so it was it
was it was a lot of work
that had to be done so i i honestly was
more motivated then like as far as i
knew i was going to make it and then
after it popped off i kind of got
discouraged
because then the real work started then
it was like damn this
is like the big leagues you know it's
not you can't just do what the [ __ ] you
want no more sometimes
sometimes you got to play the game you
know what i'm saying so
but but you know now i've i've i've had
you know
four years seeing how almost where
you're seeing how the big leagues work
you know and it's kind of like that
phase again i'm getting that that oh
okay like you got to chip on your
shoulder again yeah
it's it's weird like i have i don't know
i always knew though i always told my
mom when i was a kid i said mom
i'm going to make it in music right and
my mom was
she's the reason she's my musical i have
a music influence
so i always told her that and i knew it
i i knew i was going to make it i didn't
know how or what was
it was going to take but i just knew it
and then you know it took a lot
yeah so the things you're talking about
where it felt like music started to be
work i feel like i go through this a lot
with talking to artists where it's like
you know what are the what are those
things that you started to have to do
because i think that what you did a
great job of is
building with your fan base converting
them to like hardcore fans
and i know a lot of that is work it's
replying to comments it's dming people
this
what were those things that you could
talk about that you actually had to
start doing that were like
that maybe like an artist who's watching
this might want to start [ __ ] doing
yeah yeah um the main thing which is
something i still have a problem with
because i'm not like a
a social media person the main thing is
honestly
posting that product every day and and
if you don't have a fan base
if you if if you're posting every day
the same thing they know say you're
dropping a song every week
if if people know you're dropping a song
every week
that people have something to tell
people you know what i'm saying and that
spreads and if it's good ass
music it's gonna you know
boom but the thing that you have to do
is you have to be consistent
you have to show your face like light
used to always say you know
out of sight out of mind facts you know
what i'm saying and that was one of the
things like me and him used to argue all
the time because i'm like man i'm not a
social media person i don't want to post
you know but but then he'll tell me to
post and i'll post and
you see all the interaction i'll be
happy like welcome to my life you know
what i'm saying
welcome to my life shout out to brown
boy maj who i just got to get a [ __ ]
tick tock finally
first video got like 60 000 views it's
like
it's like yeah i i mean i hear you yeah
like those things are important though
and i'm still not the best at it but
like then
um one of the main things was so like
me and the homies me and light just you
know crashed minardi
um any of the homies gucci like we big
mike like we used to always rip
yeah forever big mike man we used to
always
hop in these cars together in the van we
had our van
we had two vans first one is in columbus
and that baby can't go
nowhere it's like bang bus yeah nah it
was a lot it was too many dudes on there
a lot of dicks in that bus we hey we
slept on hey we slept in the van for two
months well we slept in a van for longer
than that but two months solid that and
then we it ended up breaking down in la
and that's how we ended up
in l.a oh really the van's in our
driveway right now
oh wow but yeah so the fan broke down
you're like [ __ ] it i guess we're
staying yeah
and and it worked out shout out mad
child because he
let us stay with him yeah matt i know i
know you guys uh
mad child i think i heard light talking
about some like days on the road with
matt child
who it seems like an interesting cat
i love matt i've never met him but just
he just seems interesting he seems like
a peculiar
individual introvert for sure yeah
uh but i told you how that's just be
[ __ ] in this interview
we'll keep talking to his ass he's over
there saying yeah that's highlight for
those
of y'all who want to know [ __ ]
highlight
anyway um
so you guys what tour was that that like
we wasn't on tour at this point you were
just mobbing through the country so
light was on
tour with you know jelly roll
and and at this time i wasn't able to go
on tour you know what i'm saying
obviously you know
only you know only so many people get to
go yeah
i was at the bottom of the pole at this
point you know i didn't have nobody it
was it was artist development time you
know build the fan base
but but but that engagement like like
facebook was
very huge it might come up as far as
building my
face my fan base because like i got all
these people in columbus to just start
changing their like my name is to be
doobie bandit
so i got yeah to change their name to
whatever their name was bandit
and and and it just started everyone
started catching on it was the weirdest
effect
like in columbus it was like the thing
just to listen to my music
and then i started realizing okay i have
engagement i have to
you know push push it out and keep it
going you know what i'm saying so i was
constantly doing
snapchat and all that [ __ ] you feel me
and now
you know i need to get back on my [ __ ]
for i've been lazy well you were like
okay so you put your album out it's 2019
right
it's like ending 2019 yeah pandemic hits
you have a baby by the way congrats on
the baby you stopped doing coke
yeah and by the way y'all that is not
hard to do
it's not hard to stop it's not hard no
it's it's
it's oh it's hard to stop yeah yeah yeah
but yeah you were busting down the same
time though but i was
you was doing a lot of cocaine boy i was
the coke head man
i don't i'm not trying to take pride in
that but would it like like when when
you're on like a drug like cocaine
is it ad is it hard to figure out how to
be productive without it
after a while yeah see that's where my
problem lies
like i have i've been doing coke for
eight
like seven years and i'm
now almost 10 months clean you feel me
thank you and
it's like it's weird because i built my
fan base and my music
a lot of it was about cocaine a lot of
it was cocaine heavy yeah and you know
to go from that and that was the
inspiration you know i snorted a couple
lines write a couple lines
and it was just that you know now you
take that away
it's you know it's like i'm finding a
whole new inspiration but i feel good
about it
you know i feel like you know
it's i don't know but that that drug is
addictive bro it makes everything good
everything is it true when you try to
[ __ ] on cocaine it's hard to keep your
dick hard
if you do too much now if you do just
the right amount you're going to [ __ ]
all night
now you're going to cause that cocaine
dick is a thing hell yeah
so do you like you take the [ __ ] it's
like whiskey dick you drink too much
whiskey well you know what i do with the
whiskey dick if i know
if i know i'm just getting shitty i
gotta [ __ ] my wife i hit the gas station
get that
that rhino oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know about the rhino i don't know
but i know about it
i mean i'm not 26 or 33 but like yo you
get two shit-faced and you're like yo i
got i gotta run a marathon tonight i
ain't never
i'm i'm scared to pop a dick pill
because my [ __ ] worked if i [ __ ] around
and pop that but don't worry what if you
can be
sick but if you took too much cocaine it
might not work
yeah i didn't been there before but but
if you had a rhino on deck
that's why i don't do coke no more fair
enough you don't need it man stay hard
team's there and we're good
no homo but you know shout out to the
gay people you know what i'm saying i
don't want to get canceled because i
highlight saying no home on the bench
i [ __ ] with everybody mr potato head is
no longer mr potato head man i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on
it's just crazy right now like i don't
know
it's [ __ ] up right now uh so
what made what inspired you to stop the
drugs
my son having having your son well my
son is
is what made me completely stop but i
had been saying it for
like we down then last few months like
we was
like tour was tour was so hardcore
it was like every day i was high off
cocaine and you know
i would wake up drink a beer make a
drink
you know snort some lines and hit the
stage you know it was like
it was a repetitive thing it was it was
how i was being because i'm not a social
person
that's you know like that especially
when it's you know
a lot going on or whatever but i don't
know man
it was just you you felt it getting out
of control i felt
like i would even say it to the homies
and they'd just be like nah you're
playing because i was the biggest cookie
they're like no you're playing
well i literally down to that end like
the last few months
i would i would snort coke and be like i
don't like how i feel
like i'm just tired of this feeling you
know
like i started becoming i was more so
because i used to just do it
when i was in the studio so be creative
and it was to be creative and then at
the end it just was i would just find
myself doing
it you know and going out and let's
let's
let's let's find the blow you feel me
let's figure it out
man we just be partying honestly when we
came to la i feel like that's how we
build our connections
everybody knew we had cocaine they're
like yep
they party oh i met everyone
in l.a off of cocaine that's crazy
was there a point in time where you had
like any sort of scares with the [ __ ]
like where you thought you might have
taken too much
hell yeah like when you're like freaking
out like [ __ ] i might be oding and
this was the craziest part like i
remember one time
in columbus like like years ago
i was at my homie's mom's crib and we
were all just doing coke or whatever
and um bro we i was with my
my other homie bro he came through with
some pure [ __ ] and we just kept going
crazy going crazy and
i'm trying to keep up my little ass you
feeling everybody else bigger and [ __ ]
i'm like man
my body can't take this [ __ ] it i i felt
like my
my body froze up so i went out of the
room
and like laid on the couch and and i
just felt like
i didn't even have no body but i swear
to god in my heart but
i just felt my heart it was just
i'm like bro [ __ ] and and
every time i'll be like i'm not doing
that again and now do it again
damn that [ __ ] is like
it's great that's why i'm saying at
first it's the best thing ever but
when when then the fun part is over
and it becomes like the the real
addictive thing
like you said you started doing it in
the studio and then
it was like you were just doing it to do
it and that's what sucks you feel me and
and i
i'm and for ins in an instance i made it
cool too
to my fans and that's the how many hey
when you're on the road how many times
fans just throw your bags a blow see and
that's another bad thing
all the time all the time and then you
don't know what kind of you don't know
how pure the [ __ ] is you don't know what
to press with
well i could have died so many times
just off of bad drugs you know we hear
this story every day
you know i'm cool on trying to
you know worry about if i'm gonna be
alive i told you i'm going home to my
son
facts that's it that's a beautiful thing
that's it
are you gonna end up moving the fan to
l.a are you staying in columbus or what
like cause i know you got the crib out
here
yeah so i'm gonna um
i'm gonna move them out here soon we're
thinking about here
arizona actually i was gonna say you
guys let's all just do the vegas or
arizona move because everybody sucks
dick right now
it does vegas has zero state tax nevada
zero state tax i don't know if i want to
live in vegas i promise you i lived
there for three years it's a solid place
now mind you i don't know what your
gambling situation is cause if you got a
problem
you might not want to move there i'm not
a gambler also so you know
i'll go to the casino every once in a
while for fun yeah you'll be fine
i go there bro i spend a certain amount
if
after that miles gone or if i don't
you know you don't like i feel like you
know i
have come up in the same world in
aspects because i've been so
closely associated with uh wolf and ritz
you know ritz's ritz is one of my best
friends
um but i understand that there's this
world
of this white rap world
that seems that it doesn't have a very
high ceiling
yeah and i mean that respectfully right
no that's fast
and and um and shout out to jelly roll
because i think jelly roll's breaking
that mold a bit because he's starting to
like because he could sing like an angel
yeah and he's making it shout out to
jelly too because like when i first met
him he was a different jelly
for sure for sure his music is amazing
no but but
you know there's this like it's like
this little world
where it's like wolf and ritz and
jelly roll a little wide and all these
guys right
and and it feels like it's a hard bubble
to break out of
in hip-hop because you know who those
fans are
right and those fans are hardcore
and they'll put money in your pocket
loyal as [ __ ] loyalists
[ __ ] some of the loyals but it's a very
like
it feels like a very inclusive world
where it's like
it's hard to get everybody else to come
into that world and i feel like you
considering your roots and
you know highlight being jelly's dj and
you know
we all know what it is right like you've
done a very good job of
of not getting sucked into like
that bubble now you could be in that
bubble when you want to say yo look
let me go hop on trunk music three you
know what i mean like yeah yeah yeah but
i do feel like that that is a world that
like like you said the fans are loyal
you'll be able to pay your bills you'll
be able to make a lot of [ __ ] money
but it's like to be like that superstar
right
it's it's tough to exist in that
in that web it sucks man it sucks
sometimes
it's a it's a blessing and a curse you
know what i'm saying
i i have some i have the the most
loyalist fans i think in the world
i wouldn't trade them for nothing
nothing at all
they come to to every show you know they
rock the merger
you feel me they pay attention they care
about my well-being when i was saying i
was trying to get sober right
you know i have i have the most loyal
fans i appreciate them
i want to be bigger yes that shouldn't
be a problem i feel like
you know it shouldn't be a problem but
like you said
sometimes it's just the white rapper
thing
and it's that's the sucky part because i
don't want to just be that
it's like tech nine and then all the
white rappers i i
swear i swear and shout out to tech
yeah for sure texas again tech is my guy
i'm very familiar with the world yeah
exactly but but that's the thing
it's lit it's literally exactly what you
just said you know what it is
and that that is it's like loki a lot of
these fans the only black rapper they
[ __ ] with is techno
they're fast facts and
yeah i don't want to be included in them
barriers you know
i think you've done a good job of of
making
moves to not necessarily like like i
don't see you in that i'm like yo
like when i think of doobie i'm like
doobie could be the next post he could
be the next
whoever the [ __ ] you want to be man yeah
like your album to me showed me a lot
because it was one of my favorite albums
of the year the year it came out
like 2019. yeah i put it actually it was
in my top 10 and i put it out yeah i
know and uh
i was like this album to me was
it was like it was just something that
like anybody could enjoy
you know what i'm saying yeah because i
always [ __ ] with your records like i
always tell i always play everybody
nikki sixx because that's just so hard i
thought that [ __ ]
should have been a smash cocaine that
[ __ ] that's a cocaine song right
but like you're out to me when you put
your album i was like yo this is like
this [ __ ] for real for real
are we doing this at the same damn time
cheers
oh [ __ ] i had a double bubbler hold on
little double goal huh
but also you know like you said like you
you kind of came up in that world
so what where does like the is it hard
to kind of toe the line to make sure
you're not like
super associated with
the white rap world which is by the way
not a bad world if you want to pay your
bills and and you know me and ritz have
this conversation all the [ __ ] time
yeah i say i mean the main thing that i
do is
obviously i [ __ ] with my white rapper
homies you know
like we know who i [ __ ] with of course
um
but i i at the same time i try not to
just
do that you know like i [ __ ] with my
homies and [ __ ] but i don't just
you know go to them type of shows all
day you know shout out to the baby
i got a record with him i swear vezo i
swear vezo
um we just we just um you know it was
tight um
actually just recently i have a cover to
the song breakdown by tantric
and recently we just uh performed it
live with tantra
really which was actually pretty cool as
[ __ ] so just different
during covid where was this at was this
in [ __ ] atlanta oh
i don't know where it was fam listen i
was in atlanta last month that [ __ ] was
why the [ __ ] open
man i freaked where was that [ __ ]
that sounds about right it was fire was
fun it was
with tan trick yes that's like the it's
like a 90s rock band
yeah yeah [ __ ] hey you know what you got
to do you got to do that nickelback
play you know timeout which one just
nickelback anything i don't know
i always make so we all just want to be
big
the girls come easy and the drugs come
cheap
we all stay skinny cause they just won't
eat and we
a song about cocaine low-key no that's
high key
ass bruh he that's bro wrote that [ __ ]
he can play
i feel like nickelback is like the
[ __ ] like
like the it's like the walmart of rock
music
like you don't want to say you go to
walmart to get your get your clothes and
your groceries and [ __ ] but everybody's
going to walmart got some teas and some
boxers
oh my god open 24 7 biggest on the block
like yeah i don't [ __ ] with nickelback
but uh how many hits are these
[ __ ] i have god bless him
that one dude with the guy that they got
the long-ass hair what's his [ __ ]
name
i don't know shout out to nickelback i
was you know nickelback is probably it
has to be the number one
played band at white strip clubs in the
world
you ever see a [ __ ] work a poe to
photograph because i have
i haven't but that's funny
[Laughter]
definitely oh my god
that's that classic kicking in look look
how he's looking at me
hey the funniest [ __ ] this [ __ ]
said once was he said he would
tongue punch what'd you say
tongue punch a bow nah no you said
something about tongue punching i didn't
say
i would you said something about time no
you said
i think we might have been talking about
our producer
at that time i don't think i would ever
say
i would tongue punch anything
but tongue punch has been in the
vocabulary before
hey tongue punching is fun i know i
think we were talking about bro
tongue punching the bum pipe a little
bad situation buddy oh [ __ ] was it tony
chop
yeah there was definitely asian jokes
flying around that night
shout out to tony's my guy not to tony
man we love the vietnamese
do you love fluff i thought it was
it's fun it's fun i know he cuts me out
for that uh shout out to tony
all right so you um you've taken like i
wouldn't say you take because you
dropped a couple records and videos
over the quarantine and [ __ ] but i feel
like you've
you've kind of developed a very um
high output of music the last few years
where it's like we getting the song
we're getting the video repeat
song video repeat song video repeat um
how first of all why did you guys start
to do that and talk about
because your youtube [ __ ] is booming and
and i i know
i noticed you guys kind of put so much
emphasis
on youtube off the rip and it definitely
you know it resonated it resonated on
spotify everywhere else but like you
guys really double down on the youtube
[ __ ]
like why like why did you guys like
really start to dive into youtube what
was it about
like that first record that popped that
made you guys kind of say look we gotta
drop i feel like every two weeks you
guys are dropping [ __ ] it was a lot
yeah we had a so the crazy thing is
about it we had a solid campaign
and by the third it was like 10 songs by
the third one it went viral or whatever
yeah you feel me boom
bro after that we knew okay this [ __ ] is
climbing you know what i'm saying we
started seeing the numbers youtube sent
us a plaque you know
fast as [ __ ] like this [ __ ] it felt like
overnight but it was because all them
years
yeah bro literally
we just know like out of out of every
platform
youtube shows the most love like as far
as
fan base wise like there's more
interaction on on my youtube
cause your comments yeah like yeah which
is cool because a lot of artists
nowadays they're big on instagram
but they're youtube instagram don't
[ __ ] matter but but that's the thing
a lot of people think that matter
they do you know what i'm saying like
until they put the album out
and it sells 10 copies and that's that's
that's what i'm thankful for you know
like hey my instagram is popping though
it ain't in the millions but
my music is in millions multi means yeah
so it's like i'd rather have that
i ain't tripping yo what up taking a
break in into the uh the bootleg head
podcast here
to tell you about our sponsor odd socks
man make sure you go tap in with
oddssoxofficial.com
look i got [ __ ] odd socks on right
now you know what i'm saying got the
macho man randy savages you know uh
look they got the most comfortable socks
i ever put on my feet
not only that but they got the crazy
licenses they got the wwe
how about these scarface joints these
joints are crazy man so scarface
breaking bad um and their odd socks
basics line
these joints are so comfortable so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cav save 20 at
checkout
plus they just dropped underwear on them
plus they just dropped them slippers
and they got the mass
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
cab at checkout save 20
off [ __ ] with odd socks yeah you guys
are dropping like i feel like it was was
it every two weeks
it was like something like every two
weeks it was a [ __ ] video song video
song it worked
it worked it's because they know that
you're gonna drop that [ __ ]
i'm telling you they're like yup he
drops every week
and it's dope yep i'm gonna pay
attention you feel me
um and then you guys even started
shooting your own videos
yeah we we were shooting our own videos
um
honestly because like cameraman be
[ __ ] sometimes
i'm aware yeah i'll be hating that [ __ ]
shout out to the [ __ ] nice cameraman
out there
waiting forever to get the edit back
[ __ ] hey i'll be tired of that
[ __ ]
but shout out to the good cameraman
there's a few yeah
so um to now right so i feel like last
year
you had your baby you quit cocaine i
ain't i ain't been doing [ __ ] i've been
lazy bro
i'll be real you've been lazy i've been
being a dad
and you know honestly just thinking
different
you know like reevaluating
our team and just you know building
low-key like loki
just becoming more in tune with my
business i feel like when i was high
instead i wasn't really
paying attention to nothing and now i'm
just trying to you know become more
business savvy and
you know grow up i didn't even have a
[ __ ] driver's license or a car
until [ __ ] what i don't have my
license
damn but i got a car though
you just got a car how many months ago
november he said right
so a few months ago you haven't been
i've been driving but that's awesome
but you feel me you might want to get
your license yeah i'm working on it
i'm not driving down here though yeah
yeah
no uber bro let him drive uh bro you
know how much money i spent on
uber that's why i [ __ ] got the car
i'm tired of that [ __ ] exactly
uber needs to he needs to sponsor your
boy
um what so you just put a new song out
today
it was today right may friday yeah yeah
so songs out song and videos out
what's next for doobie
i'm trying to get this album together i
want to
make a solid album that i feel like is
the doobie album because i feel like
originally you weren't an album guy
it was a single single song i wasn't
then the album drops it was [ __ ]
great
it was and so now you're you're like
like honestly i was still i'm still i
was still stuck on a single thing but
then
what i'm watching is the as
it's like all the good artists
they'll they'll like spend hella time
you feel me and just drop
a nice ass album and it'll be you know
track after track and then they'll just
keep promoting off that album for
months and months go on tour you know
you can you could do a single campaign
off
of album just like how we do but just be
a part of your album and then you can
just keep
keep streams i have a feeling if you
were to do a deluxe edition of your last
album and
add all of your [ __ ] as bonus tracks on
it
you might go gold that's lightweight a
good ass idea
hey bro if you put drugs don't work all
your [ __ ]
let's say you do a deluxe with like
three new records
of three brand new songs no one's ever
heard [ __ ] it make it five
you know you got five songs ready to go
do a deluxe
uh out deluxe of your last album just to
go gold
and put all the old [ __ ] it's all
distributed through one rpm right you
guys did everything through the same
color yeah yep shout out to 1pm
bro y'all should have did that when you
dropped that album originally i'm i'm
telling you i think you guys would be
gold
that's a good idea you'd be knocking on
gold for sure oh my god
okay let's take another shot
oh no you got it
i like that yeah ring that [ __ ]
man that's crazy that's a good ass idea
i'm gonna lie i ain't gonna lie
y'all gotta get a plaque bro listen
that's what i'm saying so
okay so just like i we was talking
before the interview started
i've been sitting down with writers and
[ __ ] yeah
you you know you tell me how you feel
about it yeah
but that's the thing but i've i've
i've i've written great records made
amazing songs that just don't get the
recognition
but when you say the mainstream level i
was gonna say when you say they don't
get the wreck because i remember
talking to y'all get recognition i get
ready i'm about to say fam listen
[Laughter]
check the scoreboard now now just
because academics don't post some [ __ ]
who is he no [ __ ] him but i'm saying i i
want d
i want the plaques well i just i just
gave you a little hack
a little cheat code you did so we're
gonna
let me tell you what french montana did
his last album montana that came out
like a year and a half ago
yeah this [ __ ] had like six
records on that that were like four or
five years old
and went platinum the day it dropped he
had
no shopping with drake that came out in
2016.
he had lockjaw with kodak that came out
in 2015
and he put him all at the end of this
album is bonus tracks
platinum day one smart as [ __ ]
i'm about to drop a double deluxe
[Laughter]
they gonna think that's a mcdonald's
meal hey but
you could bro easily do it what i got so
much
i could drop three a triple dot all you
gotta do is this
you gotta say hey hello hey guys i know
i've been off i'm gonna drop a deluxe of
the album
it's just [ __ ] you already got videos
done
put the videos out put two or three of
those records at the end of the album
put all your other [ __ ] though
at the end of the album well i think
it's about time to do it greatest hits
you'll get a gold i'm telling you if you
put everything with what i'm telling you
i don't know how good your album did but
i think it did probably well right yeah
you put [ __ ] all those old like all
those old records
at the end on the deluxe dog get a
plaque
oh yeah cheers [ __ ] i definitely need
that
and you know what's great about your
situation
none of your videos except burn they're
all on your own
on your own channel so for people for
artists who are listening
if you put a video out on worldstar and
it does 100 million views
none of those views go towards your
certification because it's not on your
own channel
me personally i now in hindsight
we felt like it was as a team we felt
like it was the right uh oh yeah
you saw my putting burn out on warsaw
yeah me personally you know how so i
wouldn't have put burn
on world star on your own [ __ ] i would
have put that on my own
just because it's not the right record
for world star of course not
shout out to clever because he's he's
dope as [ __ ] and that was another thing
we know clever he's
he's that's that's his his strong suit
too so we're just
also trying to cater to that as well you
know
choppa and yeah you know but cleverest
album
yeah also clever been around a long time
yeah yeah clever low-key low g
like he started singing recently oh i
didn't know you just started
well no i just like i remember you know
i remember when he was rapping
with like without that and then he had
the record with uh
was [ __ ] the dude from funk volume
the most least popular dude with the
black eyes
dame's little brother
i said the most least popular dude there
was like
jaren benton dizzy wright hopson and
then the other guy swiss
swag okay i didn't know that's who you
saw
yeah i just seen dinner last night i bet
you did you were at his studio
i didn't know that was his like home
base him and tony choc do an album
together
uh and that was also mentioned again
shout out to tony
you know who's old it's damn rick you
know me
oh my god that motherfucker's a og but
he looks like he's 12.
i didn't think he was old oh he's oldest
he's at least what's [ __ ] face time
damn rick i'm gonna ask this
[ __ ]
i love damrick tell goose
now grab it real quick can you grab it
from real quick
do you need a pre-roll no i mean
hey joe will you hand me that full
sandbag that's right there by that water
damn i can't answer it but damn
the hell is this i mean if you just want
something rolled i got the [ __ ]
pre-roll skis broski
what is this this weed just sweet
remember the last time you came in here
and i gave you some of that [ __ ] that
melted your face off
well that's not it for the record that
won't melt your face off but it is weed
so should i it's good wheat it's good
weed it's just not the [ __ ] that i gave
you before i gave you that turtle pie
before that turtle pies
that [ __ ] was heated rasta i got some of
that in here
let me let's bust out the turtle pie man
i say hold on let's talk weed here for a
second
this is the turtle pie this is some of
the money man okay
that's for you now that
my friends i don't like you
you might wanna look at this
shout out to the turtle pie out of the
bay man where's okay yeah explain to me
where this comes from
because they need a shout out san
francisco man no what is the squad
oh so you know money man the rapper
that's his that's his strain but he does
it with turtle pie
oh my god that's yours keep that shut up
money man
[ __ ] smells amazing amazing
yeah it's good [ __ ] um so you just
dropped a record today
yes sir so we're like are you back in
the [ __ ] campaign mode bro
yeah it's gonna be bro i ain't gonna lie
we already got
the video shot the records is done
we're just dropping music now bro i'm
letting them fly you gotta think i only
dropped three songs
last year last year yeah and doubled my
spotify play that's what i'm telling
fans fan base
and i only dropped three songs what did
i tell you in there
keep pressing your line all right so
listen y'all so here's the thing
and i'm i'm completely honest i don't
give a [ __ ] i always been
i always wrote all my own [ __ ] well well
honestly the past
three years i've freestyled everything
but
i've been working with writers and [ __ ]
lately and
you know you know how it is man i'm just
an artist trying to
trying to create and [ __ ] you know so
kev
we were just having a conversation you
know and i was making some pop records
kev
said what he felt about him and that's
cool i'll rather one of them
one of them one of them one of them i
thought was corny for you and that's fun
yeah i'm glad he said that you feel me
but it's cool but you know
as an artist like artists like me i've
always been
you know real raw rough and rugged uncut
with
what i talk about
now i'm just trying to find i was you
know trying to find that record
you know like you said the plaque but
then you said some [ __ ] to get a plaque
you know i'm like oh [ __ ]
you know this we could've did this you
know what i'm saying
this guy but i don't know man yeah
i just had my first few writing sessions
they were dope but
like you were saying man it's important
to be yourself you know what i'm saying
and that's what they love me for
yeah man hey what you just said
you dropped three songs last year and
doubled your spotify listenership
that's crazy that's why i feel like
sometimes
it's so easy as an artist to psych
yourself the [ __ ] out
i'm my biggest critic but i'm saying
like bro like
you're tripping that's what i try to
tell you in there like what thank you
and i'm not even high besides but this
ain't [ __ ]
like it's so easy to psych yourself out
because you think uh you you it's easy
to go on your phone
and and check instagram to see what a
another [ __ ] is doing
and what that means when you said i need
industry acceptance i'm like no you
don't bro like you got fan acceptance
the industry will come i promise you
that's how i felt but then
like a part of me like lately since i
wasn't able to you know have that
creative like i was used to
i started feeling like i was falling off
and like and i like
i wasn't and honestly i would go to the
studio and it just wasn't coming to me
you know
all right i was it was like writer's
block like
never before you know what i'm saying it
was just rough you know when i got real
depressed and [ __ ] you gotta think
it's i'm i'm i'm living i went from
being on the tour bus for three months
then i'm at home corona locked your baby
with my son and it's complete
like you know baby daddy it's like a
flip of a coin
like it's literally like heads and tails
it's the opposite end of the spectrum
right away
i'm like damn bro and i have built the
studio in my crib and [ __ ] i'm like man
i'm still not
how i have the nicest [ __ ] and i'm not
inspired
well i know how you are too because i
remember how
uh a tentative to detail you were you
did a record for one of my artists and i
was i remember how it's like i
i can't tell when y'all came over and i
recorded it yeah you've seen how i was i
was like you're by yourself
has to be this yeah bro by myself and
honestly that's my steve
you know what i'm saying that's my stage
listen man
you know you know what you're doing dog
are you tossing the blunt or the lighter
he would like you to throw the lighter
oh hit the camera
just jesus horrible yeah i got money to
pay for ohio state my ass
hey i see this all this money through my
stock ohio state buckeye that's it a
mile stop
and the [ __ ] gave him the ohio state
[ __ ] eyes they did that
a time or two oh dude dude you know
where i got it though
is my my english bulldog ari rest in
peace
this [ __ ] still had his balls he
had his balls right
and this [ __ ] would get horny
and you know when your dog gets horny
dude they get those [ __ ] eyes dude we
gotta
right i could've could've could've could
so i would be like yo
the dogs got the [ __ ] out of ohio state
[ __ ] guys what type of
you never saw a dog get horny and try to
hump like a stuffed animal or something
no
it's like they because i like where is
handsome
handsome devil he got a dog right i know
yeah his name is
the devil listen to me
you're doing that for ratings
[Laughter]
i was like bro i'll take your dog home
right now and let him cuddle with me all
night bro
i swear to god this [ __ ] dog is
beautiful
i just want to hold them is your couch
like leather what type of material is
your cat
at home oh it's just like it's like i
don't know it's like fabric
is it okay cool it's not leather i got a
leather couch all right
right so you can just wipe the [ __ ] right
off no no so so this is where i'm going
at with it right
we can all agree right let everybody
need to okay
what we talking about listen you ain't
never slept on a leather couch
first off you always got to take your
shirt because it'd be hot very
uncomfortable to sleep on
it's it's hot you feel me and you know
when you wake up you you see
you're stuck you're peeled off yep 100
all right so
my big brother shout out gucci
he you know he's sleeping on the couch
on that leather
now past couple nights i've been up
you know i've been up in the kitchen
growing up a little joint coach got to
get up
to use the battery here it sounds like
this
[Laughter]
that whole ass though yeah yeah
when you start to slip off your ass a
little hey but a [ __ ] ass crack
this long oh you got a long
he got a long let's go like this do the
noise he got the gears
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] where are we at bro i don't know
i don't know
you don't got no cool questions for me
man you suck man
uh okay coolest question wait your
change is
uh i think your chain's about to come
off you hit it on the table ice brothers
hey ice brothers you were right i should
have sent this into you before i came to
the interview
question because it's [ __ ] give me
your craziest groupie experience
dude my girl is going to be pissed all
right what did he ask
he asked me to ask him a cool question
all right let's get it now she don't
give a [ __ ]
listen okay ask me again though what's
your craziest groupie experience
um
dude
i don't know i've had a lot of weird
ones
i can't think off the top of my head bro
i don't do you know one
i know you know
or was it personal [ __ ] you no no no i'm
trying no
no i feel like no no no i'm trying to
think bro i can't have a [ __ ] oh
i do have one okay listen okay and this
is crazy because it's funny and
and weird but not weird at all
in in minnesota all right yo give us the
minnesota story
i think it was minnesota right
he's like i don't know yet okay it's
it's highlight has crocs on he's on a
whole different level okay
so listen to me i'm doing meet and greet
yeah okay
listen i'm doing meet and greet yeah
yeah
and this was my first time and and it's
not i'm not on no weird [ __ ] i'm not
being
uh homophobic or nothing philly yeah of
course this is my first time
ever experiencing this [ __ ] and then me
and bruh we you feel me chopped
that [ __ ] was cool as [ __ ] feeling
whatever but listen to me
two girls and a dude
okay and well and three girls
okay i'm not gonna be like that three
girls
came to him in greek right one of them
was you feel me
transgender a male no he's not
transgender he's a male
a male that identifies as a woman he's
gay okay
you feel me so listen
he was more turned to them meaning
like yeah like he was a big fan yeah
and i'm like okay this is cool as [ __ ]
you feel me whatever all right
you feel me that was
very different but i was like yeah
it was cool though right now that was a
weird groupie moment though for sure
because the the [ __ ] would turn
[Music]
bro was way more turned i'm like well
you
yeah i'm [ __ ] with you like [ __ ] these
[ __ ] bro
cuz you snapping right now he knew your
[ __ ] he knew my [ __ ]
hey shout out to bro yeah shout out to
him that was a weird groupie moment
though for me
that was weird it wasn't weird but it
was weird
shout out to the gay guy who was a big
fan of doobie hey
you know you're like you're like a real
nicki minaj
trina out here with your game hey did
you hear
look how you're gripping the mic
like a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] dick yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
she said you she said you ain't [ __ ]
nikki you [ __ ] nicole's body
shout out to nikki she snapped because
damn i
oh [ __ ] if i [ __ ] her before she was
nicky i'd like
but she's like no you [ __ ] old [ __ ]
they can be like nah you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] me 500 grand ago i put 500
grand into this
this you know what i'm saying shout out
to nikki she's a goat
god bless her god bless her give me the
ladder back bro
hey uh real quick talk about talk about
scfmg man the label
what about it just what you want to know
about just shout out the [ __ ] label
man
show something to everybody bro first
off
seven oh my god that's that classic
[Laughter]
scfmg no yes no but yeah
see fmg the label man listen um
first off let me just shout out
highlight and bond
the ceos you know the [ __ ] who
handle the uh the [ __ ] that the artists
don't
understand correct you know
and then let's shout out the artist
crash monadi my brother
for over 10 years yes you guys dropped a
little joint situation
yeah blues brothers yep
shout out um swan swan is uh
our youngest and he is super fire
um and then let's go with bse count
yes he count he he's my favorite rapper
in columbus right now so he already
knows where i'm at everybody from the
labels from columbus
yeah everybody as it should be yeah
man we got we got we got scfmg to label
in columbus the actual building they got
two studios studios all that yeah
you know we got a merch shop underneath
you know if you want to buy some merch
if you [ __ ] with us that much
boom you know so so
the stay dangerous is out yes go support
it on youtube there's gonna be a lot
more music coming
yeah a lot more music boobies got a baby
stop doing cocaine life is good i feel
like you got more questions
he's just drunk i really gotta yo i tell
you what we're gonna do
highlight swap me positions while i go
piss and ask doobie a question on my
podcast
all right i'm about to piss on myself
you gotta ask me a good ass crap
no you're gonna have to drink with me
all right
hey
this is not a shot that's him that's a
double bubbler
i have a question for you hold on yeah
shut that door shut that door
i'm gonna get it oh no man oh hey bro
that
i like that
[Music]
right now or after right now oh [ __ ]
just
one drink it's your first one dick
all to right
that cat podcast what is it
what do you think about bullet calf
i think it was real i think bootleg kev
looks like
a dick with ears
what's the next question hurry up that's
it before he comes back that's how you
thought
i like black that's my brother's man
that's my dog that's my
that's my that's my dog
oh nothing we ain't saying [ __ ] about
you all right he's back
i had those intermission camps how did
that go guys no
no was there anything good yeah it was
great
it was great can i see that lighter i
drank this whole [ __ ] thing oh you
he you gave him my my joint
oh this is your lighter [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no give but give me the lighter first
give me the [ __ ] you know what's crazy
dude
i always wonder who are like who did you
grow up listening to because you have
like
people don't know like you really could
wrap your like you could really wrap
your ass off
like you got some [ __ ] that's like real
melodic that's
you know real rockish like for people
who might have tapped him but you could
really rap rap
like who were your influences growing up
um
so when i was a little kid my mom used
to like hang around a lot of rock and
roll bands
yeah like rock stars and [ __ ] so it
would be like a lot of rock stars
i'm talking about rappers i i know this
is just how it generates
that so she was hanging out around a lot
of rock stars or whatever
and um my first influence was rock and
roll
so it was always i would hear it rock
and roll and then as i got older you
know i
my dad died when i was five so as i got
older like around eight nine ten
type i started wanting to figure out
more about my father
and my father was you feel me
my mom was from you know like
a a not a good family but
my papa have had money but he didn't
[ __ ] with her
she was sent to live with her
grandmother you know like a [ __ ] up
situation but she was
she ended up being good you know all
right my dad was like kind of from the
hood
yeah okay not even kind of he was you
feel me from the south side i said i was
showing
your dad a lot of love yeah so
his influence was outcast
like i remember um
going through his cds and [ __ ] like when
i got older because
we still have the house like after he
died if he we still have the house and
it's set up
at the way he left it so shit's all in
there everything's there the way he left
it
so i'll go through his cds and [ __ ] you
know be like outcast
the shaq uh album dub shack jack deez
oh shaq diesel oh yeah [ __ ] he used to
love that [ __ ] um
it was a lot of a t aliens like outcast
was the best
so when i when i was trying to tap back
in trying to figure out who my father
was
like i knew who he was i had heard
stories but i wanted to
feel it you know for myself something
like that you know
i started tapping in the rap
and what started happening is
the weirdest the weirdest song started
in my rap career
it started made me want to rap and
you'll never think it's the weirdest
song
chris brown and jordan sparks for real
i swear to god on everything i love
where's brown and jordan sparks it's um
how you supposed to breathe with no air
eh yeah i used to have my headphones on
them when i used to love
i don't know what it was it was a great
song i jordan sparks from my hometown i
heard that song and i started writing
raps to it
to no air and i i ain't gonna lie to you
bro
i can't make this [ __ ] up bro i
literally that song
after i had tapped in and learned about
my father and everything so much i had
already been like writing little raps
that was you feeling a little corny rap
i was a kid you feel me but then that
song made me want to take it
serious and i don't know why nowhere
chris brown and jordan smart
i was an intern at a radio station when
jordan sparks was on american idol but
you just age the [ __ ] out of me so well
i know a lot of you that's crazy right
that's crazy what was like the first
rap album though that you really like
like hit you like you were like
yes like for me it was doggy style
i love that it was doggy style and bone
thugs and harmony
creeping on a come up
this is tough because i was young so you
got to mind me know for sure yeah
but at the point when it mattered
it was the card of three that's fair
carter two card three
quarter three two two yeah i was that oh
eight
that was winning that was when i was
going through the team you know the
training yeah that was when it mattered
so and that's why like me and like we'll
talk
like lil wayne's my favorite he's like
man you don't know lil wayne like i know
lil wayne and he right because he feel
me
hot boy little wayne young little wayne
you know black is hot little wayne fire
underground one that's
it you feeling it whatever carter
three's the [ __ ] carter two
three was i remember my mom she was
saudi i had
you feel me i got that [ __ ] on my mp i
had a little mp3 player
she like no you're not supposed to be
listening to this right i'm like
no no i gotta get that
that [ __ ] fire i can't go to school not
hearing this [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro i got back in the day they used
to be in the magazine
in the magazines there used to be these
um do you remember
publishing this clearinghouse you should
be able to get like highlight you
remember this [ __ ] remember
back in the day we'd open the source in
vibe magazine and you'd be able to pick
like 10 cds for like three dollars
so my grandma used to be a part of that
[ __ ]
and somehow they accidentally sent her
doggy style from snoop dogg
right and i'm like five or six so my
grandma sees the cartoon on the [ __ ]
album and doesn't realize
she's so out of her mind she don't
realize that
it's called doggy style and it's about
so my grandma gives me this tape when i
was a kid
i was like i was in kindergarten i
vividly remember being in kindergarten
and having a walkman i used to listen
like boys the man
and like all that early yeah
[Music]
all that early like brandy all that
early 90s r b [ __ ] but then my grandma
gave me doggy style
not even knowing what she gave me yeah
she changed my life
my mom would be playing that [ __ ]
heavily like doggy style changing my
life
anyway shout out to snoop um he said he
said
what'd he say uh you have now tuned into
the jackal fire
with mr dga easy dick
[Laughter]
he said he said i even let her lick my
balls yeah
was that guy and nate dawg and nate dawg
r.i.p
corrupt ass all of them listen peace
doggy style changing my life
doggy style creeping on a coma from bone
shout out to bone
um all right so we're gonna get new new
music and and
listen you have had so many
opportunities to sign in major
situations
why are you still independent because
like
i'm worth way more than them little
dollars that these [ __ ] is offering
one two people don't really appreciate
my
vision sometimes like i have a vision i
know where i want to go i know who i
am i know i know my sound
it's worked for me it's obvious you
can't keep shunning me out and this to
all the labels who feel like you feel me
i think i'm better than y'all no no i
would love
nothing more to sign to a major platform
and have somebody to have my back
but i really just genuinely feel like i
don't got my back
and at the end of the day i'm gonna keep
creating this sound building off of it
and you know what it's gonna go where it
needs to go if y'all can if y'all
you know what i'm saying if anybody has
anything
they feel like that they can capitalize
or build off that
whatever we can work but i'm just cool
i'm going to be me
ladies and gentlemen duby dubert dubert
go get that [ __ ] new song go stream
it leave a comment right here
stay dangerous doobie dude